and on mobile we need to be extra
careful images consume a lot of
bandwidth more than 60% of the bytes
that cross the web that's bandwidth we
can't always rely on or might not want
to use and images don't always work so
well on different screen sizes this
photo from the Tower of London looks
great on my new high DPI display but
when I resize the window the fixed size
image gets cropped with the same image
on my phone I need to scroll
horizontally and vertically and that's a
terrible experience the web was actually
invented with responsiveness in mind to
enable us to publish content to a
variety of devices we need to think like
that again and make sure our images work
well wherever they're seen so we can
avoid this check out the pixelation
around the eyes on the horse and this
not really seeing the surfer anymore and
worst of all this I'll leave you with a
quote create a product don't reimagine
one for small screens great mobile
products are created never porter's
that's from Brian fling so great
designers don't optimize for mobile they
think responsibly to build sites that
work across a range of devices